you need to be instinctively able to
control the machine without thinking
about it very first to the ground really
close to the limitations of the machine
it's very very difficult to describe
what the g-force is like in in our sport
because G is vertical it's called easy
and it comes down through the body like
that the the escort track is very very
different to anything we've ever done
before but the very very big difference
is that we have a standing start so we
start from breaks off and then we
accelerate down the runway and we get
whatever energy we can into the first
game then we've got a series of three
vertical turns and two she counts
obviously a lot of turns in between all
of them are variable you climb any way
you like very difficult to find the
perfect racing line that's true lines
and stuff in the way as well which is
very challenging and fantastic fun but
you know we really focus on pylons
I've never found myself at all on any
track I've had lots of pylons in my time
I'm certainly not the record holder I
didn't think but I do get to pile on
occasionally because you know you've
really got to find how close you can fly
to them because that's what saves time
I'm often asked how long I'm going to be
doing it because I'm almost the oldest
guy in this championship the answer is I
will do it as long as I feel on top of
the game I feel as much on top of the
gaming hours i did doing international
unlimited aerobatic competition in my
30s so yeah there's a few few years left
in me I think but as soon as the flame
of passion flickers or dies and I'm not
that interested I'm out of here